all influenza viruses are actually bird
viruses
the 1918 virus infected about a third of
the world's population
that would be equivalent to 225 to 450
million people
dead today huge typeface in the
newspapers saying where mass can save
your life this is in 1918
where a mass can save a life what could
have been done even at that time out of
1918 to have prevented something like
this from happening
the most important lesson from 1918 is
to tell the truth if you don't tell them
the truth sooner or later they're going
to find out
we did masks social distancing what did
we learn to
prepare for next one you know the cities
that closed down
earlier in the epidemic not only had
better results in terms of how many
people got sick and died
but their economies actually recovered
faster
and more strongly we were not told the
truth by trump
hundreds of thousands of americans
should be alive who are dead
and the reason is bad leadership how are
you processing this for yourself when
you see the madness in dc
that's a creation of american democracy
do you think things are just going to
escalate and get worse
well you keep thinking things are hit
bottom and then they keep getting worse
now you have people who are so committed
to trump they believe anything that he
says
outright lies and then fauci and trump
are going back and forth so we're kind
of like who do we listen to do you
listen to trump do you listen to fauci
if you do it right you can contain even
a disease as transmissible
as this one countries have to tell the
truth
[Music]
my guest today is john m berry who in
the past he's written many different
books he's an author and a historian
but he wrote a book that came out in
2004 called
the great influenza which in 2004
the national academy of sciences named
it the outstanding book of the year on
science and medicine
and in 2020 it came back up the charge
just to kind of give you an idea who's
called them for council before in the
past
on the topic of influenza it's both the
bush and the obama
obama administration and bill gates once
said
barry will teach you almost everything
you need to know about one of the
deadliest outbreaks
in human history with that being said
john thank you so much for being a guest
today on valuetainment
uh thanks for having me on so happy new
year
yes happy new year to you as well and i
know while we're doing this uh
uh interview together it's madness in dc
and i know you used to work over there
in dcb4 for quite some time so
how are you processing this for yourself
when you see the madness in dc
with great displeasure
uh it's an under considerable
understatement you know i know that
building well i practically lived
in the capitol for a decade my wife
worked in the senate for more than 20
years
a little bit in the house you know
every nook and cranny of that building i
know and to see it desecrate
uh you know i'm you know it's
desecration of american democracy
to see that happen here is just off the
scale you know
you ever seen it like this before for
all the years you've been oh god no
i mean you can go back to the anti-war
protests in the 60s i'm
old enough to live through that i was in
college
then and you know nobody did anything
like that
you know there were hundreds of
thousands of people's protesting
uh in the 60s but but nothing
like this disrespect for voting
disrespect for democracy disrespect for
the american way of life i think those
uh
congressmen and senators are traitors to
america
who are violating their oaths of office
and uh it's awful
how do you think this is gonna end up
because at this point uh you know
uh everyone's using the the name the
title president-elect
obviously if it goes the way it's going
president biden and kamala harris now
it's house
now with senate well i mean you know
he's going to be president and she'll be
vice president there's no question about
it uh
as they should be they won the election
you know the you know over 60 court
cases
you got to present evidence in court you
can't just make a speech and a claim
60 court cases lose every one of them
republican
leader of the state legislature in
pennsylvania
says trump's lying republican u.s
senator
trump's lying in pennsylvania republican
secretary of state in georgia
republican governor of georgia they're
lies
trump's lying republican governor
republican secretary of state in arizona
they're all lies the the person
the republican trump hired
to oversee election security says it's
the safest
most secure election in american history
so
trump fires him the you know attorney
general of the united states bill barr
authorizes every u.s eternity to look
for voter fraud
zero you know the bar was
was hated by democrats
i think for good reason i think he
played the role not of
representing the united states
but of representing uh trump but even he
says there's nothing wrong with the
election
so he goes everything that they're
saying is a lie
and you know i don't understand how
it got as far as it has in the capital i
just turned the tv on a little while
ago i would have thought they would have
prevented those
the breach uh i i guess sarah
don't want to use force to prevent them
from going forward
for fear that it would just incite
much more yeah uh but i think frankly i
think the
point is they're just about at the point
where
i would hate to see that tear gas in the
u.s capital or anything like that that
that would just be beyond awful uh
but you know uh john i i'm a guy that
came here from iran i lived there 10
years two years in germany at a refugee
camp and i've
come into the states and not watching
what's going on with politics in america
i'm noticing
the republicans are divided democrats
seem to be divided on the democratic
side you got the
aoc warren sanders camp and then you
have the biden you know
the rest of the camp and they're a
little bit divided socialism no let's
just say democrat we don't need to go
socialism
we can't stay with rad and then on the
republican side there's guys that are
mega and there's guys that are
republican and and
you know on both ends you almost see a
little bit of turmoil
what do you think needs to happen for us
to be a little bit more civil or do you
think things are just going to escalate
and get worse
well you keep thinking things are hit
bottom and then they keep getting worse
i say i don't believe you can equate the
divisions on the democratic side
with the republican side now we were
talking before we started the show
you know that i actually covered
politics
for 10 years my first book was on
you know i'm pretty liberal but you know
newt gingrich and i had a
relationship he was the first
congressman i ever had
lunch with in the 80s you know he called
my first book one of three i'm not
trying to promote it i'll never see
a penny in royalties from it never be
but he did call my first book one of the
three best books ever at non-washington
you know back in the 80s
it was like two lawyers fighting in
a courtroom tooth and nail then they go
out and have dinner
there were close friendships close
friendships
uh between people in both parties we
were talking earlier you know tip
o'neill and ronald reagan got along real
well
uh danny rossinkowski the chairman of
the ways and means committee and bob
michael the house republican leader
were were very very close friends uh
you know and that has
dissipated there's there's essentially
none of that
anymore i the divisions on the on the
democratic side
are you know fairly
standard you know they don't hate each
other
inside the party they disagree over the
issues
uh they've always been like that
the republican side has gotten a lot
more extreme
you know there aren't any moderates or
very very few people
who would be considered moderate left in
the republican party who were the
classic
fiscal conservative uh
they may claim to be but you know they
give away the taxes and so forth and so
on
uh and now you have people
on you know who are so committed to
trump they believe anything that he says
uh you know outright lies that
have been disproved by every republican
and yet
people were just committed to trump
uh that's never happened
in uh recent you know i
i did drop out of grad school i almost
got a phd in american history i'm gonna
say
has it never happened ever in american
history i look back
and uh i'm trying to think go back
certainly not through the 20th century
i'm scrolling through in my head
the 19th century you know there were
people committed to andrew jackson but
not like this
uh john adams you know when when
jefferson was elected president
adams wouldn't go to the inauguration he
left washington in advance
but there was no question over handing
over power
uh now there
it's never been anything like this and
we've never had
a leader in either party who incited
followers the way trump has done
uh you know it's
again we didn't you didn't have me on to
talk about this stuff but
you know it's happening in front of our
eyes and
i was watching fox which i don't usually
watch
but they were saying all the right
things
that this is a desecration of american
democracy
this is not who we are and yet
it's happening here and it needs to
stop what do you think the 74 75 million
folks who voted for him are most upset
about
well you know they've been lied to ever
since the election
so i
don't blame them for believing
some of the things that they've been
told you know
tucker carlson for example just to give
you
a single anecdote you know had this
uh thing on about somebody dead who was
voting
a name whatever the name was john doe i
don't remember well
a reporter went out and tracked that
down and discovered
it was a 95 year old woman
who used her as some women do they
went by her husband's names mrs john doe
so
it wasn't john doe who voted she signed
in as mrs john doe
and it was misreported as her deceased
husband voting
we'll tuck her cows in other words there
was no dead person voting
so tucker carlson makes a big deal out
of claiming a dead person but he never
corrected himself
he never issued a correction explaining
no it turns out
it was actually the widow signing mrs
john doe so if that's what you
see all the time i i'm not surprised
that some people believe it
you know for me i'm a registered
independent i was a former democrat
then i went and became a republican then
i became an independent
eight nine years ago i became an
independent myself okay and i can see
from the outside
myself uh i think clinton was a
uh uh good president i think it was good
for economy and him and newt were good i
mean it worked very good for america i
know
republicans probably didn't like clinton
and i know democrats didn't like newt
but they work good together you know the
whole
conversation you and i were having with
tip and the gipper you know the book
written by chris matthews
how they worked together years ago where
they would fight both irishmen
and they would have a beard together um
you know
i sit there and i wonder to myself you
know when you say
uh uh you know tucker carlson comes out
and he says he doesn't go back and
apologize and say that
i mean that's being done by by both
sides where the russia story you heard
for three years and nobody ever came out
and said that wasn't a true story
and then that came out and was an
inaccurate story i think
both sides of the aisle got to take some
responsibility i don't put it on the
politicians i think media's divided
america
at the highest level and we're getting
caught in a middle
fighting each other over them enticing
more eyeballs to want to watch fox and
cnn to get more advertising dollars
what do you think about the role msm's
played uh mainstream media has played in
dividing uh
many of us well first i wouldn't say
there was nothing to the russian
deal there was something there now you
know maybe it
didn't rise to the level of
a felony although you know that's
questionable
if you actually read the report but you
know we don't want to talk about that i
mean adam should
adam schiff said for sure there is
something you know the way he made it
seem like this guarantee i mean you got
to realize
to use words like he used i mean all of
us sat there and said
there was some scandals with russia so
again i just want to make sure
well even if you recall lamar alexander
who did not run for reelection but voted
against hearing witnesses
at the senate trial he said well the
reason he voted against witnesses was
the democrats proved the case
now whether you want to say it rose the
wrongdoing rose to the level of
impeachment you know
that's that's arguable uh
in a reasonable position to take but you
know
again we don't want to talk about that i
would
agree with you that
you know fox msnbc
cnn they
you know like to cite
because it does get clicks yeah or
you know uh clicks being
you know obviously print media you know
you know what i'm yeah what i'm getting
at
and i would like to see a little bit
more reporting on that
uh i mean just there's a lot of news
that happens
all the time that never gets reported
because it's not exciting again enough
but it's real
has real impact on people's lives and
it's ignored because the latest
you know outraged by one side or another
is all they talk about on all three of
the
those shows uh or networks uh
you know i would agree with
with you there for pro might not go as
far as you go but
essentially in agreement uh
yeah i'd be curious to know what happens
with that because i think
on one end you know you most of us are
emotional creatures you know so
so let's just say on both sides out of
uh 78 million 74 million that voted
what percentage really did a lot of due
diligence before voting let's just say
80 percent just voted emotionally 20
research a little bit more out of the 20
that research a little bit more
say 10 of them extensively went into it
to look at it
so media ends up controlling the
majority of us because we're like oh my
gosh i can't believe what's going on so
i i think i think there's got to be
something about that because it's
unfortunately we are looking like fools
to the world forget about us fighting
each other we're looking like fools too
if other countries are watching them
right now they're laughing saying look
at what's going on
to supposedly the greatest country in
the world look how divided they are
you know and anytime they're divided you
know it's a very easy thing to come in
infiltrate but you know let's let's talk
about your book because i think that's
uh that's the one thing i do want to
spend some time talking with you about
specifically
the great influenza which you know
newt gingrich said it's the third best
book
you know he's ever read and for him to
say something like that well he didn't
quite see
oh i know i you know want to correct
that what he said was my
first book which was not the end you're
right
the book yes that was a book on amer
on the congress really uh in the reagan
administration you talk about the
ambition and the power
is that's correct yes so that that's
still for him to say that about a book
that you wrote but let's talk about the
great influence of 2004
so for some folks that haven't seen an
interview of yours i think you did some
stuff with the folks at library congress
and other interviews you've done
what happened in uh with the great
influence if you want to kind of walk us
through with the story and some of the
stats
so the audience can come up to date oh
you know
uh an animal virus all influenza viruses
are actually
bird viruses they all start in birds so
in a sense are all bird flu but
obviously they circulated mammals
uh and a new bird virus jumped species
to humans uh we hadn't seen it before or
at least most
hadn't seen before there were there are
eight gene segments in
influenza seven of them came directly
from birds one
it may have passed through another
mammal before it got to humans
on the eighth it spread worldwide very
rapidly you don't need airplanes to have
a pandemic there were
pandemics that made it from africa to
asia
to europe even to the americas going
back into the
1600s
it infected about the 1918 virus
infected about
a third of the world's population it was
much
much deadlier than covet 19.
and it killed between 50 and on
coordinator nobel laureate
uh made this estimate in the 1940s and
it's been confirmed by modern
epidemiologists
probably between 50 and 100 million
people died obviously that's a big range
if you adjust for population the world
back then was
less than a quarter of the size of
today's world so that would be
equivalent to 225 to 450 million people
dead today uh so the worst worst case
scenarios for covet 19
nothing like that uh thank god
uh and you know so that virus was much
more virulent
it it also killed these people
in an incredibly compressed period of
time probably two-thirds of the dead
died
in the fall of 1918. uh the pandemic
stretched over a couple of years
and in a particular city it was even
faster than that it would probably be
six to ten weeks
most of the people who died were
uh adults between the ages of 18 and 45
or 50 probably about two-thirds of the
dead so that's very different from
covet-19 and very different from
ordinary influenza
possibly as many as eight percent of the
world's population
this would be on the worst case uh of
people in the age group that age group
died
in a matter of weeks so
it was pretty violent and
the western world was at war and
because of the war every government that
was fighting
was focused entirely on the war
and for that reason
uh governments tended to
minimize the pandemic in the united
states
wilson the president at the time never
made a
single public statement of any kind
about this pandemic
uh and in an effort
to there was a concern that any
that wilson didn't want any bad news
about anything
period we didn't want any
news that might hurt morale this had
nothing to do with the pandemic
they created an infrastructure in
advance of the pandemic
again nothing to do with the pandemic
something called the committee for
public information
a propaganda arm the architect of that
committee said nothing in experience
tells us that truth is superior to
falsehood the only thing that matters
is its impact on what you say so the
government
created this entity
that was geared toward telling lies
to keep morale up for the war uh
the government also passed a law that
made it punishable by 20 years in prison
to quote utter write print or publish
any disloyal profane scarless or abusive
language by the government of the united
states
that law was upheld by the supreme court
by
oliver wendell holmes and an opinion
from two phrases from that opinion
uh survive one is you don't shout crowd
fire in a crowded theater
and uh clear and present danger and and
then the government enforce that law
vigorously they sent a
congressman sentenced to prison for 10
years a congressman
you're kidding me uh so this is the
1990s
so that's yeah so that's the context on
the one hand
and again not prior to the pandemic
only because of the war the government
created an institution designed to lie
to keep morale up
and at the same time punish people for
criticizing any action by the government
so there that's the context that
influenza arrived in
as a result you have there's no tony
fauci in 1918
you had national public health leaders
associated with the government saying
things like this is ordinary influenza
by another name it was
called spanish influenza although it
didn't start in spain
uh and they said or you had nothing to
fear
if proper precautions are taken and yet
people could die less than 24 hours
after the first symptoms
and they could die with horrific
symptoms
probably the scariest would be they
could bleed not only from their nose and
mouth
but from their eyes and ears that's a
pretty frightening symptom
uh so people are dying
in some cases with these horrible
symptoms and in some cases very rapidly
and a lot of people are dying and the
government is telling you this is
ordinary influenza by another name you
have nothing to worry about
i could you know go into greater detail
but we're going to be talking for a long
time
so i'll let you ask some questions so
john what
how was the media at that time covenant
covering this i mean obviously we don't
have
the the fox cnn cbs abc any we don't
have the kind of media that we have
today
who's writing about it opposing uh
president wilson while he's saying
everything's fine don't worry about it
who's opposing and telling stories about
what's really going on
pretty much nobody in 1918 uh
you know the the in the country
uh number one they were patriotic and
wanted to support the war effort
number two they had that law that i told
you about a minute ago that if you
criticized the government you could go
to jail and a congressman was sentenced
to prisoners
uh so in most cases in most cities
the uh newspapers simply
went along with the program and
printed lies i'll give you a couple of
examples
in philadelphia which was one of the
hardest hit cities in the united states
hundreds are dying every day in
philadelphia probably about fifteen
thousand total
when they finally and they're using
steam shovels to dig mass graves
you literally have priests in
philadelphia driving horse-drawn carts
down the street
calling upon people to bring out their
debt
so when they finally in philadelphia
closed saloons closed theaters closed
schools and so forth and so on
one of the newspapers actually said a
direct quote
this is not a public health measure you
have no cause for a panic or alarm
unquote and yet
people you know their neighbors are
dropping dead you know they're mass
graves being dug
they're using reusing coffins
because they didn't have any coffins and
the newspaper
is saying this is not a public health
measure
so i mean how stupid did they think
their readers were
the readers knew what was going on um
another example in in little rock you
know i
i quoted uh a doctor in in uh
an army camp uh a couple miles out
actually i guess seven or eight miles
outside of little rock
uh talking about thousands in the in the
base hospital the you know card is
overflowing
with with beds beds outside the hospital
uh and he writes there's nothing here
but death and destruction
just a few miles away in little rock
arkansas
the arkansas gazette princess big
headlines spanish influenza
same old chills and grip and
and you know it's just total dismissive
just like
was ordinary influenza you know
there are a couple of exceptions uh
there's a small city in wisconsin where
the
newspaper started to print the truth and
the army started to institute
prosecution against them
under that law i mentioned a little
while ago
although the prosecution was dropped as
the pandemic proceeded san francisco is
is a uh was pretty exceptional
in san francisco uh which got hit pretty
late
actually the uh in you know
most cities say they're saying things
like this is ordinary influence by
another name
san francisco the mayor the business
leaders
trade union leaders and the medical
community all got together
signed a joint statement huge typeface
in the newspaper saying where our mass
can save your life
uh what is the matter within 18 this is
in 1918.
where a mass can save a life say save
your life
so that is a very different message than
saying this is ordinary influenza
by another name which was the most
common treatment of it in the press
or a third example in phoenix they wrote
a little bit about it when the
disease erupted in boston which was the
first place in the united states to get
hit by the
disease came in waves and the second
wave was
the deadly wave so
when it's in boston they write a little
bit about it in phoenix
when it's in new orleans they write less
about it in phoenix
when it's actually in phoenix it
disappears from the newspapers
not a word initially because
again they didn't want any bad news out
there that might hurt the war effort
eventually when it was impossible to
ignore
uh the phoenix paper did start writing
about it but
again initially to
keep morale up and so forth and so on uh
they ignored it you know in other
newspapers they simply they
didn't even print names of the people
who died
and you know all of this had a
impact on the public and it wasn't what
they wanted
instead of keeping morale up it hurt
morale more than
the truth would have uh because people
knew again their neighbors are dying
in some cases the bodies are lying in
the house for days because there's no
one to get take it out
and they ca and people knew this was
happening all around them they knew that
they were being lied to by the
by the media and by the public officials
and all that did was alienate them and
and
caused them to feel that they had no one
they could rely on
except for themselves uh and
you know it's sort of split society
apart john for you
did you ever sit down and have a
conversation about this with your
grandparents
i'm assuming your parents are probably
born in the 20s
or or late teens actually my mother just
died at 102 and she was born in 1918.
oh and you got him you kidding me wow
but when i first started working on the
book
you know my grandparents were dead uh
but i had
anon who was considerably older than my
mother
uh and when i told her that i was
working on the book
i mean she sort of like grabbed her to
her chest and said
oh my god then you know that's the only
time she ever saw her father
to cry that was because a couple
directly across the street who had a
couple of kids
you know both of them died leaving
several orphans which was not uncommon
because as i said earlier the
18 to 45 is like the peak a
which people were dying so there were a
lot of orphans created
well that i was asking too but by the
way sorry for your loss i mean
it's it's so interesting you write this
book uh uh uh
you know the great influence of 1918 and
your mom's born that you're
uh but you know it's always interesting
when you talk to your parents and your
grandparents you know when i talked to
my dad and i said dad what was it like
with the shah's father versus the shah
when he was in charge or what was
mossader
like and you're always curious you know
to to see what it was like during that
season but
you know when you look back now i'm sure
i mean this is your topic this is what
you've written about this is what you
research
one how was woodrow wilson judged his
legacy based on this
did it at all impact his legacy because
at that time
maybe we didn't have the media and
number two looking back
now based on more experience that we
have today
and having gone through a few other
epidemics pandemics
in the recent decades what could have
been done
even at that time out of 1918 to have
prevented something like this from
happening
well first thanks for your comment about
my mother
uh you know historians haven't written
much about this
and it's hard to say exactly how wilson
was viewed because of the pandemic
response at the time there was
essentially no
federal infrastructure for there was a
public health service
there was no national institutes of
health which was actually created
partly in fact primarily because of the
pandemic although not for a few years
everything was handled locally
anyway uh
and it's it's hard to see you know the
war
was so much more dominant in the news
it's hard to say how
wilson was evaluated or because of this
also we didn't have
the notice that we had this time around
you know there was a first wave in the
spring
but at the time it was almost
not noticed at all and you know for for
one thing
the virus changed and the first wave was
very mild
i'll tell you how mild there were over
ten thousand soldiers in the british
grand fleet
which patrolled the coast of europe
which missed
duty who missed duty in the middle of a
war to report for sick day
bay with the first wave only four out of
10 000 died
that's pretty mild that's how mild the
first wave was
so that first spring wave nobody paid
any attention to
they were hit by surprise with the
second wave the virus became much more
very
much deadlier and the whole thing was
over so fast it wasn't really an
opportunity
to evaluate plus medicine was much more
primitive
the only thing that they did have
in 1918 was the same thing
that we have today social distancing
you know hand washing business closures
so forth and so on but those were
decided
on a city-by-city basis not even
by uh by governors it was always up to
the mayor and local
you know there were very few statewide
closures i'm assuming that's documented
right meaning that it's easy for
anybody to be able to research to see
that it was city by city not stable
right
yeah you can read in in pretty much any
local paper it's it's
always the in in 1918 it was always up
to the mayor
who who made decisions uh
very few states uh
so the the id you know wilson really
wasn't judged on the performance of the
federal government that and again it was
so fast one of the biggest differences
between
covid19 and 1918
is the speed the two biggest differences
are the virulence of the virus and the
other is the speed of movement
influenza is a much faster moving
disease so
as i said earlier in any particular city
the second wave was usually gone you
know whole
cycle was six to ten weeks
so it was it was quite different in
terms of evaluating the
actions of the government one of the
reasons i got involved
in pandemic preparedness was because
what they call non-pharmaceutical
interventions what do you do when you
don't have
any drugs uh was based on studies of
what happened in 1918
and we did discover that
you know the cities that closed down
earlier in the epidemic before the virus
was widely
uh disseminated in their populations
and stayed closed longer not only had
better
results in terms of how many people got
sick and died
but their economies actually recovered
faster and more strong and more strongly
than uh cities that that did not do that
interesting so you know looking there
looking now what we experienced you're
talking about here's a virus that is
more of the are not score it's more you
know it can spread faster and
people are dying within 24 hours and
some instances it's pretty ugly where
it's not just bleeding bleeding from the
eyes and ears and
the scary side to go within 24 hours and
the ages you're talking about
it's 18 to 45 which is not necessarily
the ages we're looking at right now
and then we look at cover 19 with what
we experienced the last say 12 months
that's what first week of january
december 27th is the first one they find
out and comes here it gets pretty bad in
march and then it takes off how do you
think we handled it do we
overreact you think it was done the
right way you think we could have uh
you know uh comparable with numbers to
what happened with the influenza it's
nowhere near the numbers we
obviously any loss of a lot one to
anybody who loves them that's more than
anyone ever wants to have but
statistically speaking it's nowhere near
that how do you think it was handled
with covet 19 uh and what we did the
last nine
10 11 months well of course it varies
country to country so if you
want to look worldwide there's a
tremendous range
iran has not done very well
one of the reasons is the iranian
government
lied to the public i'm sure
you probably know more about what's
going on there than i do
in the united states in terms of the
developed world i think we've done just
about the worst
again because we were not told the truth
by
you know cheaply by trump you know why
he made a decision to politicize
masks i mean how is something as simple
as that
how does that become a political
statement you know if you look at the
countries
around the world that have done well
yeah
it's not just you know you could say
that japan
and taiwan and thailand
and so forth that those
their cultures are different so maybe
it's
easier for them to do things as a
community than it is for the united
states
but look at australia
australia's culture is probably in the
sense of individualism and things like
that
probably as close to the united states
as any country in the world
maybe even including canada uh
australia has 25 million people
and they have just over 900
deaths so if you adjust for population
that would be the equivalent of 13 000
deaths in the united states
instead we have over 350 000 deaths
so you look at what australia did
and you look at our death toll
and you can judge for yourself whether
or not you know
it's the same virus we have the same
tools to fight the virus
what's the difference the difference is
leadership and the way
it's been handled you know the and the
economic impact
has been much greater in the united
states than it has been in australia
because you know they
yeah i mean like airplane the airplanes
are flying overhead
i mean they're flighter jets but not
passenger
there's no government restrictions
keeping people off airplanes
people aren't getting on an airplane
because they don't want to be in an
enclosed space even though actually the
circulation in an airplane is very good
and it's it shouldn't be that scary but
that's why the airplanes nobody's
traveling
it's not because of government
regulation
uh so i would say we've done a very very
very poor job
ethic areas like because when you talk
about masks like i remember
when fauci first came out on 60 minutes
in march he said
masks are not effective you know and if
you wear them it's not going to be that
effective and
you know you know and then uh when
trump's about to shut down china
pelosi goes to china say hey it's not
fair it's racist why are you shutting
down china it's not you know where it's
not a big deal we should stay open
and then biden comes back and says it's
you know we shouldn't be doing this and
then he turns around and says was the
right decision made
and then and then fauci and trump are
going back and forth so we're kind of
like who do we listen to do you listen
to trump
do you listen to fauci do you listen to
michael osterheim who do you listen to
and then do you and
everybody starts reading your book let's
find out what can we learn from 1918
so what i'm curious about is it you know
it seemed like from the beginning
fauci and trump were not on the same
page so which part of the area
because i don't think this is the last
time that we're going to have another
uh epidemic pandemic i think you agree
with that
there's going to be absolutely so my
biggest concern is i'm 42
and i run multiple businesses i got
three kids one on the way and these are
young kids eight seven and four
and so if in the next time a pandemic
happens what set of
standards do we hold that president is
that president automatically going to
panic
whether he's a democrat or she's a
democrat or a republican and they're
going to say
shut it down don't shut it down you
should shut it down what if this well no
one's died dude why are we going to shut
it down
so i'm worried the way we handle this
one is going to put the other president
such a corner
where they almost have to make certain
decisions that could impact the economy
again so
i'm looking for more since this is
something you're not i'm not an expert
in this area you are what
let me see okay you know
first let me talk specifically about
mass and i'll talk more generally
uh initially i you know was on
you know i was honored with all the
networks even including fox
uh and i was saying no masks aren't any
good
and that was based on influenza and it
was based on 1918.
now even in 1918 they actually ran very
good experiments
that hold up today and they could tell
you how far respiratory droplets travel
and so forth and they found
in 1918 they knew that putting a mask on
someone who was sick
was very helpful in protecting people
around that person
but they did not find that putting a
mask on
healthy people would for the general
public
was useful based on that data which i
was very familiar with
and i don't know how familiar fauci
actually knows a lot of history whether
he's familiar with that specific data
i'm not sure
but at least my own position was based
on data
that changed because
influenza has essentially no
asymptomatic transmission
it does have transmission before you get
symptoms
you can transmit the disease but it's
for a relatively short period of time
then we discovered that this disease has
a lot of asymptomatic
and pre-symptomatic transmission that
changes the equation on the masks
so you get new information you change
your position
if you've got a brain uh
so specifically on mass there was that
on the more general point
you know the the reason i was asked to
get involved in the
pandemic preparedness stuff under the uh
bush administration
was again because of my knowledge in
1918 and
my message in many meetings was always
the same
the most important lesson from 1918 is
to tell the truth
when the only weapons that you have to
fight the disease
are going to be public health measures
they're not going to work if the public
is not going to
listen to your advice and unless the
public believes
what you're telling them they're not
going to listen
if you tell them the truth if you don't
tell them the truth sooner or
you late them the truth and you hope
they comply
in those early meetings you know going
back to 2006 2005
maybe even
we were unanimous in those meetings that
no politician
not the president not the secretary of
health and human services
no politician should be the spokesperson
we were unanimous in those meetings that
to retain your credibility you wanted to
have
a scientist or you know a physician
and the perfect guy this is before your
time
uh but going we were talking about the
reagan administration earlier
everett coop who was a surgeon general
in the reagan administration
he would have been the perfect person as
a spokesperson
uh i don't know if you remember anything
about him at all
or how many of your viewers remembers a
long time ago was 40 years ago
but since we didn't have everett coop
that if a pandemic happened then when we
were in these meetings we figured tony
fauci would be the best guy
and tony was not a member you know i
know i'm not well
but i know him we have a lot of mutual
friends uh
tony was not in those meetings uh
we weren't scientists we were public
health people and so forth and so on who
were who were
not lab scientists which he is primarily
but we all felt that he was
the guy so
you know cdc
you know somebody should be the
spokesperson who comes out of the
scientific community and
can retain the credibility because no
matter
how popular any president is
and no matter how much truth he's
committed to telling
in the best case 30 of the american
public are not going to believe anything
he says
sure and in the worst case 55
aren't going to believe them so that's
why you don't want a political figure
so that's the number one lesson which
was violated by
this administration and worse
you know they as we know now he told bob
woodward on february 7th he knew that
this was a deadly virus and he knew that
it was airborne and all this stuff
and he just didn't tell the public
the truth he politicized the irony is
that i think if he had handled the
pandemic
half decently he'd have been reelected
you know you lived in germany merkel's
approval ratings
went through the roof the highest she
ever got she's
in her approval ratings because she was
very forthright
she's assigned you know a physicist as
you know is her background
she was telling the german public the
straight
dope from day one and her popularity
went through the roof
the only time in re in trump's
presidency
that he cracked 50 percent in the
approval rating
was back in march when he said we're at
war with the virus
people want to rally around a leader
in a crisis and if he had maintained
that tone
instead of trying to minimize it i think
and if he had done a better job
you know number one i think it would be
a lot fewer
americans dead and number two
it would have been better for the
economy
and number three probably would have
reelected him but he chose not to go
that route he's very short-sighted he
likes to win
the day without looking at
the month much less the year
so on any given day maybe it was better
to tell somebody
the equivalent of this is ordinary
influenza by another name
which is essentially what he said
uh over a period of time as the death
toll mounts up
you know that came back to on
john um question with you regarding when
i was going to the future my concern is
the next one we're gonna have okay
so let's talk about now with the next
one before we wrap up is
what did we learn now what to do with
the next one we like
i tell you me as an amateur okay we
thought it took even
fauci said it takes at least 18 months
to come out with a vaccine well we were
able to do it faster than that right so
that was impressive
we came up with it i don't know nine
months which i i didn't think it was
going to come out in nine months
pretty impressive a week after election
boom pfizer says we have a 94 and a half
efficacy
moderna comes at 95 efficacy and then
you you got the
pfizer says we're 95.5 whatever but
anyways we have a vaccine
that comes up right okay we did masks
social distancing what did we learn to
prepare for the next one airports
travel you said something early about
influenza that you don't need airplanes
to
have a virus you can do it through birds
so just maybe talk from your standpoint
of preparing for the next one
well again i think the same lessons that
came out of 19
are confirmed by this one number one
tell the truth to get your public the
public on your side
certainly don't divide the public tell
the truth
keep a consistent message have a
credible spokesperson that's all
sort of the same thing number two
these so-called non-pharmaceutical
interventions work
they work better than any of us ever
imagined
you know i supported them but based on
the 1918 experience i was kind of
skeptical
skeptical about how well they would work
but we have learned
much to the amazement of the public
health community
that if you do it right you can contain
even a disease as transmissible as this
one and this is more transmissible than
influenza
you know i i cited uh you know australia
a few minutes ago
they have fewer than a thousand deaths
and out of 25 million people that would
be the equivalent to 13 000 deaths in
the united states
taiwan hasn't had a case of influenza
since
of cobat 19 since april 13th
you can do it right we didn't
it's that simple but those are the
lessons that it is controllable the
other thing is the technology we
you know because the bush administration
really started
this massive program to prepare for a
pandemic they expected it to be
influenza
but it applied to any respiratory
disease
part of that was creating
putting money into basic scientific
research on vaccines
and as a result that's why we were able
to get the vaccine so quickly
there was an infrastructure there was a
platform
of how to make a vaccine that could
be applied to basically any virus
uh and they just plugged in the genetic
code for the
spike protein into this platform that
already existed that had been developed
you know hopefully in the future we'd be
able to do it again but not every virus
is
as susceptible to a vaccine you know
we've been working on a vaccine for hiv
for you know 35 years and we haven't
gotten there yet
same thing for influenza we've been
looking working on a vaccine for
influenza we have vaccines but they're
not nearly as effective as the one
against covet 19.
uh so improving the basic science
getting uh investing in basic science
investing in the public health
infrastructure
that's one of the reasons why the
vaccine rollout
is so screwed up is because there is
essentially no
public health infrastructure again
another basic scientific
investment in broad spectrum anti-viral
drugs
we originally thought that we would have
drugs that worked against cobit 19
before we got a vaccine
we really don't have any effective drugs
yet except for dexamethasone
which which helps significantly but
that's a long way
from a magic bullet investing in that
area of research
you know further investments vaccine and
public health infrastructure
and telling the truth i think those are
the
the main lessons that and maybe
throw in one other thing and that's
surveillance for new viruses
uh you know the biggest concern had
always been an influenza pandemic like
1918.
the world health organization
did create a worldwide surveillance
system
looking for new influenza viruses
so the alert alerted very early
in the process you know that
needs to be expanded and again
countries have to tell the truth china
did not tell the truth in sars
they improved a lot when we were
concerned about bird flu
they did not tell the truth in covet 19.
and they're still hiding it you know
just i think it was
yesterday they're still negotiating
earlier they had agreed to allow
who investigating team into the
country to try to track down the source
of covet 19.
and yesterday it turns out they're not
letting that team in
yeah quote negotiating unquote
over what they're going to do so they're
still not willing to tell the truth in
china
that's very helpful by the way i mean
what you said was very helpful
uh you know how much of this from your
point of view i think you're in in this
area you know
you're holding chinese china's foot to
the fire and
trump's foot to the fire will foot to
the fire wilson was a democrat trump's a
republican
china is somebody that's a very
controversial country right now because
both on the left and the right and i i
guess my question for you and this will
be because when you said
the influenza wasn't decided by the
governor or
wilson it was the social distances in
the mass was left alone to the mayors
and he said a lot of that is documented
that you can find it
how how much of what we experienced the
last 9 10 11 months
would you say is the responsibility of
china how much is trump how much is
the governors of states for states like
california i'm originally from i lived
in california 24 years i came to texas
how much of it is china how much of it
is trump and fauci and his
administration how much is
uh uh the state's governors on how they
handled it themselves i'm curious
because
as somebody you're starting to notice i
was in florida last week looking at
homes
and florida my realtor said something
very interesting to me
he says patrick i know you're coming
you're looking at homes i just want you
to know
this is the wrong time to negotiate i
said what do you mean
he says it's not on your side right now
don't negotiate with the seller
i don't understand what you mean by that
that's what buyers and sellers do he
says you're right except he's got 50
offers
because so many people from new york are
moving to florida the leverage is not on
you
the same with texas i put my house on
the market two years ago john
when i put on the market two years ago
for one year i got nothing
zero offers i put the house on the
market three weeks ago with the plans of
selling
it in six months 24 hours i got two cash
full price prices i wasn't planned
i wasn't ready for that we have to move
out of our house so i'm saying this to
you because
again i think what we learned as well by
states is you gotta also look at how
your state handles it
i wanna hear your thoughts so is the
blame more on china uh should they go
through the tribunal and be held to
at the course to see how they're gonna
be held accountable is the president
found you or is it governors what would
you say
well in terms of china i i don't want to
allocate percentages but
you know this is not
a virus that was put together in a
laboratory that's
crystal clear there's not a scientist in
the world
worth of salt who believes that i don't
think in terms of
could it have been an accidental release
well it's almost impossible to prove a
negative but there's
no evidence whatsoever that that is the
case
but you can't really prove that that's
not the case
you know it's theoretically possible but
highly unlikely
that's a skilled laboratory
and wuhan they know what they're doing
very very and no evidence that they were
working on
this virus you know could china have
contained the virus
and prevented it from getting out will
that involve
would have involved
you know that's also theoretically
possible if
everything worked perfectly and china
came down
on it with the same hammer that they did
on i guess january 23rd or 24th when
they closed wuhan
it's theoretically possible
might not have been possible because
that virus
you know it takes a while it starts it
crosses the species barrier
it starts to circulate in humans
it's not recognized immediately people
have to get sick and go to the hospital
before it's recognized at all
you know and particularly with a
relatively
long incubation period as long as 14
days people wuhan's
11 million people they're traveling all
over the world
without knowing that they're sick
without you know so i don't think it
could have been contained
so i you know the blame for chi you know
the h1n1 turned out to be a very mild
virus but when it first started the
so-called swine flu from 10 years ago
you know the initial reports were 10
case mortality
so that looked pretty scary you know was
that mexico's fault
no it wasn't mexico's well it could have
happened anywhere in the world
there's evidence that the 1918 virus
started in the united states
and i put that in my book although since
my book was published i actually think
it started somewhere else so
you know china's hard to figure out
certainly they have not been forthright
but the people who suffered most from
that were their own people
you know and and the the doctors that
they put in
and you know there were four of them one
of whom died
uh who were trying to get the truth out
uh
you know so let's move
from from there to fauci
uh you know he's not perfect none of us
are perfect
you know i said the same thing he said
about mass we talked about that earlier
the data changed the information
changed so you change your opinion
uh i think the
the cdc's failure on testing which is a
huge failure
that was not trump's fault
he may get the blame for it because it's
his administration
but that didn't rise to the level of
you know the white house when they were
in the first weeks of tracking the virus
in the united
states you know clearly
it was circulating before we realized it
was circulating
uh in terms of
acting on closing borders and things
like that
you know closing borders can slow the
spread of a virus if you get it
very very very early but it depends on
the virus
if it were influenza because the
incubation period is so much shorter
it wouldn't have made much difference
there were studies that
uh models that showed this is prior to
this pandemic
if you were 99 successful in closing a
border against an influenza virus
it would delay the spread of the virus
and its arrival in your country
by three weeks
that's not worth doing because of the
economic disruption
but this virus moves much more slowly
again one of the biggest differences
between
cobit 19 and influenza is the incubation
period and then
the serial uh infection
after one person gets sick then the next
person gets sick and the next person
you know so whether it makes any sense
to close the borders
depends on the virus uh
in influence i don't think it would as
it turned out but we didn't know it at
the time
it would have helped initially
with this virus uh but once
the virus gets going inside your country
it doesn't make any difference
in terms of the 357
000 deaths at the latest count as we're
taping this
you know how much of that is trump's
fault
and i'm not going to
give a percentage but i would
as i said earlier you know you look at
canada on a per capita basis much lower
death toll
you look at australia as i said earlier
an infinitely lower death toll
yeah that's on trump we could have and
should have done much
much better before this pandemic the
world health organization
rated pretty much all the countries in
the world and their pandemic
preparedness
the united states came out number one
supposedly we were the most prepared
country in the world
but we didn't use it you know the idea
you were talking about governors and
and mayors and so forth you know the
failure to use the defense production
act the idea that states were bidding
against each other
for you know the ppe's
that's crazy that should have been done
by the federal government and then
allocating based on need you know in
terms of
closing individual cities down versus
the governor
you know you had in georgia
you know the mayor of atlanta wants to
close mid
the the city down
george is forbidding that from happening
uh similarly there were tensions between
mayors
and the governor and in florida
and and probably elsewhere i know in
louisiana
there wasn't attention but the governor
of louisiana
the state of louisiana was much less
aggressive
than the city of new orleans new orleans
at one point where i'm sitting
at one point we had the highest growth
rate of cases in the world in the spring
and the mayor shut down i live in the
french quarter you know the bars never
closed here and the bars were closed
i think new orleans has done a lot more
better than most places in the south
because
we had aggressive leadership from the
mayor
there's credit i would rather have
credit go around than blame go around
but i don't think there's any way
of getting out of this without saying
at a minimum tens of thousands and
probably hundreds of thousands of
americans should be alive who are dead
and the reason is bad leadership
one of the things i i struggle with i
had newton a couple months ago
maybe maybe six weeks ago i had new dawn
i think i just spoke to
a dr cyril wecht which you would
probably know who he is he's the
pathologist you know award-winning
pathologist you know 21 000 autopsies
he's
the one that came out 1972 first one to
hold john f kennedy's brain a civilian
to do that a doctor
and many times when i sit down and i
talk to folks
obviously you know where they're at
politically if i talk to gloria allred
which
we've had her on you know which way she
leans if i talk to newt
you know which way he leans if i speak
with president bush you know which way
he leans
if i speak to you you know which way you
lean i if i if i speak to anybody where
politics are involved
you know which way they lean one of the
things that
you know i i i struggle with is
things that we're not on the same page
with i'm confused why the left and the
right
is not on the same page when it comes
down to china
that confuses the hell out of me because
you know i get it if you say well it's
trump's fault okay i get it if the right
says it's fouchy's fault
he kept flip-flopping and changing okay
no it's trump's fault at the end of the
day everything rises and falls on
leadership
you can't dispute that that is exactly
what you can't say it's not my fault
you're the president everything falls on
you fine yeah okay where
you brought up uh the gentleman's name
who worked with reagan
i think he was the one that wasn't she
was that yeah
he was the one that was leading the aids
uh uh
pandemic right that's what he was doing
okay yeah and that's great that's a good
playbook that we have on what to do
but you know the the the one part is
um on one end you're saying they're
trying to negotiate that people come on
inside and go and look at to see what
happened with the pandemic
that's ridiculous yeah it's ridiculous
and at the one time one of the
a journalist kind of like you a lady
comes out and says look this virus is
deadly and she's now getting jailed for
four years
just because she told the story and the
truth and now she's going for that
i don't know that's the one part that
concerns me i get we have differences on
policies
pro-life pro-choice fine i get that we
say nra
guns we need more you know background
checks sure i'm military i get it
we do need to have more people need to
be trained when they have guns but there
are certain things we've got to be on
the same page with our enemies
is it doesn't care if you're left right
or the middle you know they they want to
take control of us if they can and china
and russia are both
enemies uh so my challenge becomes how
they're going to be held
responsible for this uh more than
anything else i don't think that's a
political message i think that's a left
right middle i think that's a red white
and blue message of us
being on the same page with that so
anyways i i appreciate you sharing your
thoughts if you have a rebuttal for that
i'd love to hear it
well it's more an agreement i'm well
you know i mean they didn't create the
virus they didn't try to infect the
world with it
uh they mishandled it there was no it
but so did a lot of other countries so
when you talk about liability
for what is a natural event
that's that's pretty tricky their
political actions
yeah i mean what they're doing in hong
kong
uh you know what i'm talking about what
i'm saying is we haven't even been able
to go out there and do our own research
and due diligence on it right it's kind
of like well now you're not welcome here
and there's no free press
we don't have a cnn fox abc cbs nbc over
there
you know what's going on we don't even
have a social media it's a secret what's
going on over there so
that's why i don't i don't know if we're
ever going to get to the bottom of it to
find out really what they did and what
their involvement was
i think both sides are assuming the
sides that say it's their fault and the
size that are saying
we don't know if it's their fault or not
i think we need to investigate and i
don't think they're going to let that
happen with us
well again what do you mean by fault
you know i i don't the idea that they
you know what would have been the
difference let's say
on january 8th instead of january 10th
the world
got the genetic information on uh this
virus
or let's say they got a you know there's
some indication that it was even earlier
than that
that they had the genetic code by
earlier we're talking about a few days
earlier
what difference would that have made
in terms of the world developing the
vaccine it wouldn't have made any
difference
are you kidding me i mean everything is
about momentum everything
well you're talking about we're talking
about four or five days earlier
i think they might have released a
genetic code if i'm
so if i'm an ally with you and you're
making 550 billion dollars of tax
revenue off of me every year because of
import export
i would expect you to tell me the second
you find out anything now if
for us a day is too long for me we're
allies i'm making you a half a trillion
dollars a year
i'm not saying they were right to
withhold but when you're talking about
holding them making them liable
what are the damages that resulted from
a delay of four or five days and
releasing the genetic damages are the 50
million
people that were working in the
restaurant business that are unemployed
right now and
the jobs of a beer alcohol all the
regular people that have regular
the same thing with the same it wouldn't
have stopped the virus from spreading
around the world
if if i'm an ally to you if you and i
are married to each other husband and
wife
married to each other hey when something
happens tell me about it we're an ally
we are in bed
when when you become business partners
with somebody
and you have any kind of material
information that's going to affect the
company that we own together you got to
tell me about it
and we're i agree with that i'm done i'm
just asking you
if they had for example release a
genetic information
four or five days sooner
see would there have been any difference
in what happened now
i don't really i actually you know you
could argue maybe pfizer would have
ended up
releasing you know announcing that they
had a vaccine
results before the election instead
after the election
that could have affected the outcome of
the election
so from trump's perspective the four or
five days may have made a difference
in terms of the death toll or the
efficacy of the vaccine it would have
made any difference
that's not at all what i'm asked just so
you know i'm not at all asking about the
election that's not that's not like the
law
i i hear what you you know do i think
china handled this right now
i think they lied and they're still
hiding stuff
you know we thought they had learned
their lesson after sars
they didn't you know they were very
cooperative
on on bird flu and this thing comes
along
and they go back to the way they were
with sars
you know my biggest thing is why are we
why are we
making giving them a pass here i don't
understand why we're giving them a pass
that's the part
that deeply concerns me when we're
giving them a pass
knowing they're celebrating new year's
and wuhan doing backflips with tens of
thousands of people outside
and the most incredible place to be on
new year's eve which is new york
watching a ball drop if you've ever been
there it's magical
and our folks are not out there we're
all home afraid going to sleep at 11 45
which is pathetic that's not the
american way you know and i'm not i'm
not even an
i'm an immigrant i wasn't even born and
i'm talking about the american way so
what i will say about you john i i
became
smart in the last 84 minutes because of
you and i appreciate that and i'm
grateful for your time
uh and you know i i don't know why you
said earlier i will never see a penny
of it if people buy the book why did you
say that i you said that quickly and i
didn't oh i'd say
well no i'm depends on the book we were
talking about my first book
which is out of print so the only way
you can get it
is used i can use bookstore
so i will never see that i got it
okay but the great influence that you
are going to see
that's in print yeah okay so if
if the audience is watching this and
you've never uh
bought the book if you haven't many have
we're going to put the link below for
people to
order the book john do you want to give
us a 30 second your thoughts
uh on the future how do you how do you
think the future looks are you
optimistic about the future
i'm very optimistic i think uh in in
terms of the vaccine
uh there is as i'm sure you know
uh the mutation in the virus which makes
it more transmissible
and that's a little bit scary right now
it
it looks like the vaccine will still be
very effective against that virus
so we're in a race between getting the
vaccine distributed
and the spread of that virus i think
the polling has improved in terms of
people who are willing to
take the vaccine and i think that will
continue
uh i got vaccinated a couple of days ago
actually
uh i didn't jump any lines
i'm old enough that in louisiana if
you're over 70 you got it i just
happened to get lucky in terms of
getting
signing up on a website before it
crashed
crashed right after i signed up
so so you know the vaccine works
we also in terms of the longer term
future
for the next pandemic and as you
said you expect more and you know i mean
there's a virtual guarantee there will
be future viruses
jumping species from animals to humans
you know we do know two things we've
improved our scientific infrastructure
so that we can get a vaccine faster than
anybody ever imagine
and it still took nine ten months and
it's going to take more months before
you distribute it
so you're still in a best case
you're going to take at least a you know
a year 18 months
after a virus enters the human
population before you get a widely
distributed vaccine
that is the best case because the
production and distribution you can't
really accelerate beyond what we've
already done
so the other thing that we learn from
this
is how to handle it properly
uh the question remains
whether or not whoever is in leadership
will make the right decisions for
15 years i went around giving talks
and i ended up pretty much the same way
that we know what to do but the person
making a decision
is going to be above the pay grade of
some public health commissioner
and will that person listen to the
scientific advice
or will they be making a short-term
political calculation
and that is going to remain the question
into the future because that's the human
equation is always going to factor into
it
and i'm not dissing the impact on the
economy
you know that is part of what you weigh
when you make these decisions
but they should be made for the benefit
of
the society and not a short-term
political calculation
and again that's going to be up to the
individual who's
in a position of power and that's
unpredictable
i hope the right people are doing so
much research and reading books like
yours to be prepared for the next one
because
if we don't learn our lessons from this
one
and repeat it again that just shows a
lack of leadership and lack of research
and lack of preparation
and and uh that's not okay you know in
business we say you can make
mistakes and that's okay new mistakes
are fine
so repeating the same old mistakes is
ludicrous and i hope we don't make that
both as a society as a country as a
leadership
at the top and obviously the people that
are involved
um who are making the decisions with
health as far as the folks in the
fountain community
and cdc so john with that being said
thank you again for your time really
enjoyed it thank you
yeah i enjoyed it too thank you you're
very welcome so what you think about the
discourse the back and forth to china
the story of what's going on in dc with
republicans democrats
fouch there was a lot of things that we
covered i'm curious to know what you
took away from that part and
if you enjoyed this interview if you
watch the whole thing and you enjoyed
this interview i think you can also
enjoy the interview i did with stephen
gundry
top cardiologist in the world and if
you've not watched that click over here
to watch it take care everybody bye